[Música]
economía en directo américa me acompaña
en el estudio jorge hurtado jorge muy
buenas noches comenzamos hablando sobre
el gas ruso nuevamente la propuesta de
europa para vivir sin la dependencia de
este gas procedente de la federación
rusa bueno hay países como alemania que
afirman que el tema del gas ruso o la
energía como tal es un tema de seguridad
nacional así lo dijo el canciller alemán
olaf scholz quien durante una visita a
una fábrica de bombas de calor y una
infraestructura de hidrógeno advirtió
que la necesidad de reducir el consumo
de combustibles fósiles y desarrollar
las energías renovables en ese país es
sumamente importante en febrero con el
inicio de la invasión rusa ucrania los
suministros rusos suponían un 55 por
ciento del total de importaciones de gas
que recibía alemania porcentaje que a
finales de junio de este mismo año se
había rebajado al 26 por ciento el
objetivo alemán es tener los depósitos
de gas en un 95 por ciento para el
primero de noviembre esto para
garantizar con ello la seguridad
energética en invierno actualmente está
en el 64,4 por ciento y de acuerdo con
el plan del ministro deberían estar en
el 75 por ciento
el próximo mes de septiembre
escucharemos
lo que también aprendemos es que las
cosas que son importantes para nuestra
prosperidad económica para la protección
del medio ambiente y el clima son
también las que pueden contribuir a
mantener la vida asequible cuando esté
slim advanced black tengo porque una
cosa es segura el uso de recursos
fósiles costará cada vez más en vida
final en un coste eso en cuanto alemania
jorge pero en el reino unido también se
están preparando para este invierno para
que existan algunos apagones debido a
las casas de gas bueno y se habla de que
el reino unido podría enfrentar un
déficit de capacidad eléctrica
aproximadamente de una sexta parte de la
demanda máxima según el gobierno incluso
después de que se hayan encendido las
plantas de carbón de emergencia las
temperaturas inferiores a la media y la
reducción de las importaciones de
electricidad de noruega y francia
podrían llevar a cuatro días en enero en
los que el reino unida tendría que
activar medidas de emergencia para
conservar el gas y estas medidas por
supuesto incluyen apagones o recortes de
gas es en este momento entonces no pide
que el calentamiento global provoque un
invierno mucho más cálido hablemos ahora
de esas dos empresas que ya anunciaron
inversiones importantes en la
fabricación de chips en eeuu hablamos de
las empresas micrón y qualcomm que
invertirán 44 mil 200 millones de
dólares esto según la casa blanca que
vinculó las inversiones a la ley recién
aprobada en el congreso para subsidiar
la fabricación de microprocesadores esta
ley subsidia con 52 mil 700 millones de
dólares a fabricación de microchips y
fortalece también las cadenas del
suministro para mejorar la posición de
eeuu frente a uno de sus mayores
competidores comerciales como es china
la casa blanca reveló que micro en
invertir a 40 mil millones de dólares
para fabricar chips de memoria en eeuu
esto crearía 8 mil nuevos empleos y era
que la cuota de mercado estadounidense
en la producción de micro chips de
memoria pase del 2% actual al 10% eeuu
considera la fabricación de
microprocesadores como una cuestión
clave para la economía y por supuesto
para la seguridad nacional especialmente
por el gran dominio de mercado que tiene
actualmente china en este campo y para
los que se preguntan por qué son
importantes chips son importantes para
la fabricación de vehículos para
encender los aires acondicionados y para
otra cantidad de electrodomésticos
hablemos ahora de bitcoin que volvió
otra vez al terreno negativo y también
de las bolsas como los fuera los
principales parqués hoy bueno la cripto
moneda más famosa cayó más de un 4% y se
negoció en torno a los 23 mil dólares la
caída arrastró a otros token como éter
un cardán o y solana la caída es previo
a la publicación del dato de inflación
en eeuu se espera que haya una leve
rebaja de los precios en el último mes
pero es el dato es más alto de lo
esperado la script o divisa debería
perder todavía mucha más fuerza pero si
es más bajo podría haber más liquidez
para la decisión que tome la reserva
federal en ese país pero no sólo la
script o moneda fueron se fueron a la
baja este día en las acciones de estados
unidos cayeron luego de una previsión
negativa de un importante actor
precisamente en la industria de
fabricación de chips que aumentaron los
riesgos de una recesión mundial en
europa las acciones cayeron mientras los
inversores esperaban con cautela los
datos claves sobre la inflación en eeuu
pero en américa latina la bolsa
y revirtió pérdidas de hasta el 0 52 por
ciento y cerró como un aumento del 0,23
en la sexta sesión consecutiva en
positivo esto fue principalmente animada
por las acciones del banco itaú un día
después que divulgaron sus resultados a
propósito de brasilia que estamos en ese
país hay cifras de inflación cayó
levemente para el mes de junio hay que
tomar en cuenta que brasil tiene una de
las datos de inflación más altos en toda
américa latina' la inflación interanual
a jim basillie retrocedió el
11,80 del 11 89% de junio al 10,0 7% en
julio esta desaceleración fue propiciada
por la reducción del costo de los
combustibles de los nueve grandes grupos
analizados por el instituto brasileño de
geografía y estadísticas
dos registraron de inflación o bajada de
los precios estos fueron el transporte y
la vivienda mientras que subieron el
resto de los grupos entre ellos
alimentos y bebidas la semana pasada el
banco central de brasil elevó la tasa
básica de interés en medio punto
porcentual hasta el 13 75% anual su
nivel más alto desde diciembre del año 2
16 muchas gracias jorge por esta
actualización del mundo económico
ponemos punto final a la economía aquí
en directo américa a continuación el
debate
[Música]